mais d'abord ces images elles ont jailli
à la surface de la mini chilienne comme
un éclatant signal d’espoir à 700 mètres
sous terre la vie des 33 mineurs coincés
depuis 21 jours s'organise ils ont reçu
des vivres ainsi qu'une caméra vidéo ils
peuvent désormais montrer à leurs
proches et au sauveteurs à quoi
ressemble leur quotidien dorothéolique
prise au piège à 700 mètres sous terre
et on voit des hommes détendus organisés
presque serein
j'embrasse ma femme mes parents mes
frères tout le monde je pense à Mariana
on sera très vite dehors je l'espère
cet homme à la barbe blanche entame une
visite guidée du refuge il montre le
coin à pharmacie équipé d'alcool de
médicaments et de dentifrice envoyés par
les secours l'un dit-il c'est le coin où
nous nous divertissons les mineurs ont
bricolé un jeu de dominos le refuge ne
dépasse pas 50 mètres carrés mais des
galeries peuvent encore être empruntées
avec des engins toujours utilisés par
les mineurs les hommes semblent dans une
phase euphorie qu'ils entonnent souvent
l'hymne national même s'ils savent
qu'ils devront attendre pour être
secourus peut-être un mois peut-être 3
les familles qui ont pu visionner la
totalité de la vidéo de 45 minutes sont
rassurés
ils ont le moral ils chantent il salue
leur famille leurs épouses leurs enfants
ils sont vraiment bien
cela dit il va falloir préserver la
santé physique et mentale des 33 mineurs
et pour ça des experts de la NASA
spécialiste en confinement dans l'espace
devrait arriver sur zone des astronautes
ou encore des sous-mariniers vont
également prodiguer des conseils aux
mineurs quant au ravitaillement il est
en train de se roder grâce à ces tubes
d'acier descendus par un étroit conduit
toutes les 30 minutes dans les
profondeurs de la mine
nourri soigner les mineurs semblent
prêts à poursuivre les preuves d'autant
plus qu'ils sont un pays entier derrière
eux